fifa counter-strike league of legends
nombreux sont les yvelinois qui passent
du temps quotidiennement sur ces jeux
vidéo les études sont maintenant
nombreuses à montrer les avantages de
leurs pratiques
si certains apporte une flexibilité
cognitive d'autres permettent d'acquérir
diverses connaissances
parce que la majorité des documentations
sont en anglais et le jeu vidéo est
assez basées sur les mathématiques par
exemple nous améliorer notre réflexion
notre stratégie est encore nous
rassembler avec les autres autre
avantage du jeu vidéo
les intelligences artificielles
permettent de voyager et de découvrir le
monde
la réalité virtuelle est un marché en
croissance elle plonge son utilisateur
dans une réalité créée on a le jeu
développé par microsoft qui s'appelle
flight simulator qui est un jeu où on
pilote un avion et on peut réellement
être dans l'avion
à voir le cockpit est vraiment être
plongé dans le jeu vidéo et avoir cette
sensation voyage l'époque actuelle est
marquée par des périodes de confinement
et de couvre-feu conséquence le nombre
de joueurs augmenté de 11 3% en raison
du lien social à porter sert à un peu
moins de s'émanciper
on peut oublier le stress des cours et
les transports cela permet aussi
développer des relations on va direct
des avec des personnes virtuel
l'avantagé avec les jeux multijoueurs
c'est vraiment qu'on est connecté avec
le monde entier et que ça permet de
pouvoir faire des rencontres après
l'annnonce du troisième confinement la
vente de jeux vidéo pourrait connaître
un nouveau rebond depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire leurs ventes auraient
augmenté de 183 %